hey I'm Dan Perrault and these are 10
reasons to see Deadpool number 10 hard
our action the Deadpool action is so
graphic it got banned in China so for
all your responsible parents out there
it might not be the best film to take
your kids to but for all you
irresponsible parents go right ahead
your kids will love it
number 9 the twisted humor as the
trailer show us this will be one of the
most quoted ly offensive movies ever
with lines like you look like Freddy
Krueger just speak topographical map of
Utah gets my mom every time number 8
they've been working on this for a long
time Ryan Reynolds was first attached to
play Deadpool in 2004 shortly after
starring as that other Marvel character
in blade Trinity but let's not talk
about since then Reynolds has been
determined to deliver a Deadpool that
will satisfy the fans number 7 New
Mutants Deadpool takes place in the same
universe as the other x-men films
including that first film with Deadpool
x-men origins Wolverine let's not talk
about that either
this movie will introduce new x-men
characters like negasonic teenage
warhead and the new mutant villain angel
dust number 6
no 4th wall this movie doesn't just
break the fourth wall it demolishes it
Deadpool will address the audience
directly and probably make fun of other
superhero movies as we see in the first
trailer
Deadpool not so subtly makes fun of
Reynolds other superhero flop Green
Lantern let's just pretend Ryan Reynolds
didn't do superhero film number 5
Colossus
one of the most powerful mutants from
the previous x-men films is back it's
the same characters before but with a
new actor and a buffer look that's a
little closer to the Colossus from the
comics number 4 Ryan Reynolds but do I
need elaborate number 3 it's faithful to
the comics at comic-con Ryan Reynolds
told Hall H it's the most faithful
adaptation of a comic book to a movie
he's ever seen the Deadpool team is so
confident they got this right they
tweeted a page from the script along
with written notes by Deadpool that we
probably shouldn't show you number two
it's the perfect date movie not really
but that's what some people will think
when they see the trick billboards
promoting Deadpool as a rom-com and
Deadpool does open on Valentine's Day
weekend so for all you guys out there
trying to make it a Deadpool date good
luck it's not
problem with me because because I don't
have a girlfriend hmm number one the
Stan Lee cameo x-men co-creators Stan
Lee is making another Marvel cameo in
this film and I won't tell you what the
Cameo is but it's awesome so I want to
tell you but I won't I won't tell you
but I want to tell you it's really bad I
want to tell you I can't I will tell you
okay so he's it and and it's just
hilarious me it was worth the price of
admission thank you for listening and
that's ten reasons to see Deadpool I'm
Dan Perrault check out Deadpool in
theaters February 12
[Music]
you